follow your passion first first first
first first first I had a summer - I
play basketball when I was like 10 or 11
years old and yeah come playing and I
don't score one point the entire summer
really not one chance just cuz the ship
sink and all of a sudden we jump off to
swim to another [ __ ] like that you don't
do that right if you can win
championships in front of everybody then
you could miss the playoffs in front of
everybody need motivation
peas Kobe Bryant and here's my take on
his top 50 rules for success
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one make sacrifices there's a choice we
have to make as people as individuals so
if you want to be great at something you
have to make the inherent sacrifices
that come along with that family time
hanging out with your friends said the
age of 18 I knew that I was not going to
be stopped
this was my life we've all can be
masters at our craft but you have to
make sacrifices that come along with
medinet decision rule number two one
move at a time once you have the
passionate thing that you're passionate
about now you can look at other people
or other entities or other things or
works of art and you can draw things
from that to help you be better at what
you buy looking for those common
denominators which I don't even know how
do I prepare how do I prepare how do I
study how do i Ryu the game how do you
build your game and my response is much
like the way he builds products and you
think sequentially oh yeah you look at
this the end result of what you want to
create but in order to create that
there's so many other little things that
go into this massive entity that or
device it's no different than building
my basketball game
you start with what do you want your
game to be will we make your game most
unstoppable or hard to deal with and now
you work backwards from there and you
start building it one piece at a time
one move at a time one counter so
there's a lot of similarities there rule
number three trust your skills well you
just kind of have the the fearlessness
to really take those shots you know
because you missed those shots then you
have to deal with the the criticism you
have to deal with us
right right so you know a lot of times a
lot of people kind of get a little
apprehensive about taking their shots
because of that while we missing but you
start smiling away just thinking it out
the word well it's it's it's always it's
always been a myth to me as to why
certain people don't really like those
situations because of the the pressure
at you know because we've all lost games
before so it's not like by you missing
that shot you about to face something
that you will never face again or having
faced in the past you know I mean we've
all come up short it's you know one time
or another so just gonna kind of let it
all hang out and you don't trust your
skills and trust the work that you put
in rule number four use your scars as
weapons so that means taking things
using things in your life that are scars
using those moments as a weapon right
using those as using basketball is kind
of like a vehicle through which to
express yourself right so it doesn't so
at that moment for us to face the
Celtics again it's not about the Celtics
it's not about your opponent it's about
you it's about you taking it and it
struggles and channeling that through
the game right as it as a way to to
unleash right so now I became a matter
of how do i express that to them how do
I get them to that point where they
figure this out for themselves cuz I
can't say hey listen I need you to play
harder so when she - well I had to share
my story I had to open up to them and
let them know I've dealt with things
this is the things that I use this is
how I go about focus this is how I deal
with adversity this is how I deal with
you know arguing with my wife the day of
the game is showing up to the game and
still having that focus to be able to
play like I used those things to open up
with them and then in turn they were
able to to take those stories and make
them their own also if you want to learn
to build confidence like hoping other
entrepreneurs check out my 254 series
the links are in the description below
if you wake up in the morning and you're
dreading going to work dude do something
else do something else and those are
hard decisions to make but when you make
those decisions it's a very liberating
experience Weehawken
the Masters at our craft but you have to
make sacrifices that come along with
mending a decision there's certain
things that we want to get to but we
have to pace those out because we have
to have absolute focus rule number five
focus on each day well you just got to
put one foot in front of the other and
you know sometimes I think you for
myself it's easy to become distracted a
little bit and start trying to look at
the Bible but the final picture is gonna
look like and you know when you do that
you can you can easily become frustrated
with where you are at the moment so you
know my advice is just to focus on each
day and you know you have a plan in
place of how you want to improve and how
you want to get better and you stick to
that plan and then trust the fact that
you know every day that you you know
stick to the plan I'll get you to your
end result rule number six don't be
afraid of confrontation I'm not gonna be
afraid of confrontation to get us to
where we need to go
I think it's there's a big misconception
where people think winning or success
comes from everybody putting their arms
around each other and singing Kumbaya
and patting them on the back when they
mess up and that's just not reality if
you're gonna be a leader you can't
you're not gonna please everybody and
you gotta hold people accountable even
if it's even if you have that moment of
being uncomfortable always compared to
sitting across from somebody at the
dinner table for sitting across from
each other and would you rather sit with
a person that's gonna be afraid to tell
you have some in between your teeth and
let you walk around the restaurant smile
and stuff like that when you guys dump
in between your teeth what would you
rather sit with somebody that's not
afraid to have that moment of being
uncomfortable to tell you you have
something in routines so you can get it
out and don't look like an idiot run
everybody else all right I'm gonna tell
you you have something your team no
matter what even if it hurts my feelings
I'm gonna tell you guys something
I'm gonna tell you and then it's your
choice if you want to get it out they
just want to leave it download like an
idiot
rule number seven be competitive when
it's hard is everybody wants to compete
it's knowing how to compete and also you
know I you know true competitive
instinct really kicks in when you're
down you know like I said a lot of
people were competitive as things that
are rolling their way you know things
that they were naturally good at nobody
takes a true competitive person when
things are down like this to really step
up to the playground glass roof rule
number eight just keep going up most
importance like I was such a die-hard
fan Laker fan growing up man and just my
personality like it was for me to ask
for trade or to go play someplace else
to try to chase the championship That's
not me man that's not being that's not
what my career has been about that's not
who I am and I stay with it and stuff
that I've been through in my life and in
my career and just taught me anything is
the fact that you'll have good moments
you have bad moments have great moments
you have horrible moments you just keep
going through all of them and then
things work themselves out rule number
nine thrive on being an outsider and
I've always had someone best
performances
[Music]
fans
actually we love it problem
they don't understand who I am
not only am i comfortable being outside
that has become a source of motivation
so when I go to these places and you
rule number 10 compete with yourself and
he gets to the gym at 4:30 in the
morning to see Kobe just drenched in
sweat like he jumped in a pool and then
Kobe wants to make him do conditioning
and weights for a couple hours so then
when the trainer goes to sleep after for
a few hours he comes back to the gym at
like 11 a.m. and he sees that Kobe never
left the gym at all because he had to
make sure that he made 800 shots before
he left after he's been working out for
hours and hours like you think this is
new to me this is an excerpt from Shaq's
book talking about Kobe well they had a
few so he says he was so young and so
immature in some ways but I can tell you
this
everything Kobe is doing now he told me
all the way back then he was going to do
it we were sitting on the bus once and
he told me I'm going to be the number
one scorer for the Lakers I'm gonna win
five or six championships and I'm going
to be the best player in the game and I
was like okay whatever then he looked me
right in the eye and said I'm going to
be the Will Smith of the NBA Shaq used
to say he would catch Kobe Bryant on the
gym and the court without a ball
practicing place this is who he is it's
just ingrained in him to do whatever he
can
first light as your Shack said this this
is funny love the inputs you know what
it probably helped them see a lot of
people want to they say that they're
gonna do something Kobe Bryant does it
right talk is cheap but Kobe did it
because he competes with himself every
single day he wants more out of himself
every single day
it's that competitive drive to be the
best that carries him carries him
through practices it carries him through
the weight training sessions
conditioning making sure that he gets
eight hundred shots every day carries
him to work on his craft when no one is
watching
rule number eleven follow your passion
follow your passion first first first
first first first when I retired from
the game I said they're asking kind of
all the wrong questions
it was the biggest industry I can get
into and it's all the wrong stuff and
you got to sit there and ask yourself
okay what am I truly passionate about
what do I enjoy doing and when you feel
that way honestly I mean you feel like
you have never worked a day in your life
it's the most fun thing in the world you
get up in the morning excited about what
you're doing and you got to be really
honest with yourself about it if you
wake up in the morning and you're
dreading going to work dude do something
else do something else and those are
hard decisions to make but when you make
those decisions it's a very liberating
experience and you'll find out that the
rewards will come rule number 12 find
mentors you've mentioned that you you've
been lucky enough to have mentors in
your life such as Anna Wintour the
editor of Vogue Arianna Huffington
Johnny I've of Apple I'm notorious for
just cold calling people in I just pick
up the phone call them up and let's just
talk you know there's nothing in
particular I just want to talk and just
you know explain to me how you see your
business you know how do you operate the
business you know Johnny Ives in
particular he's just fascinating his
process of creating design and when I
was playing I used what I did that I
used to try to connect the dots between
how John Williams will compose the score
for a film
or Johnny eyes would design new at Apple
product and how does that connect to how
I play the game the basketball is
there's something there that I can learn
that can be used when I step out here on
the court there's lessons that surround
us I mean it life is basically a library
just it you know all we need to do is
just open our eyes and look and and ask
and read accordingly so is that
something you were doing you were
building those relationships even but
outside of your interest as a
businessman really even as an affiliate
and a basketball player yeah I miss the
curiosity I think the curiosity is the
most important thing I mean it's it's
you know it's sounds really weird to say
but you mean like leadership lessons
yeah I learn leadership lessons just
from walking in the park is just
observing nature and the sons
relationship with nature and
relationship with the moon and the Sun
understanding when to be present and
when they go away right because as a
teammate it was like dude the sun's out
all damn long you're gonna sunburn a
hell of a lot of people right so if I'm
playing this game and I'm on top of my
guys for 48 minutes dude you're gonna
sunburn every single team made there
right so the certain times was important
for the sudden of you president
sometimes it needs to go away right and
but their life less is that's around us
at all times and I've always been
extremely extremely curious about those
things rule number 13
outwork everyone I've been with you for
a long way at the one moment that stands
out out of we've done I don't know how
many done we've done no play 800 events
the one time was 4:00 a.m. we went out
to practice at 4:00 a.m. and that was
your idea to do it well then you know
all these Nike people are like no no no
no no let's not let's not do that and
then you're like let's do it at 4:00
a.m. so you got security
you got brand marketing a sports
marketing going no no no no no no that's
not good you're like let's do it because
that's your sustenance right I mean to
me it just makes complete sense not to
us
see we all right what you usually I'm
sleeping at 4:00 a.m. you're you're
working out I like about that okay so if
if your job is to try to be the best
basketball player you can be all right
to do that you have to practice you have
to Train
you want to train as much as you can as
often as you can so if you get up at
10:00 in the morning
train at 1112 say 12:00 train at 12:00
train for two hours 12:00 to 2:00 you
have to let your body recover so you eat
recover whatever you get back out you
train start training again at 6:00 train
from 6:00 to 8:00 right and now you go
home and shower you dinner you go to bed
you wake up you do it again right those
are two sessions all right now imagine
you wake up at 3:00 you train at 4:00
you go 4 to 6 come home breakfast relax
so so now you're back at it again 9 to
11 right relax and now I'm just on
you're back at it again to the 4 and
have you're back at it again you know 7
to 9 look how much more training I have
done by simply starting at 4 all right
so now you do that and as the years go
on the separation that you have with
your competitors and your peers just
grows larger and larger and larger and
larger and larger and by year five or
six doesn't matter what kind of work
they're doing a summer they're never
going to catch up because they're 5
years behind so it makes sense to get up
and start your day early because you can
get more working is that genetic or is
that something you you engrained and
trained yourself
no it was just you that for me it was it
was just common sense like I can okay if
I start earlier I can train more hours
and I know the other guys aren't doing
it because I know what their training
schedule is right so I know if I do this
consistently over time it's the gaps
just gonna widen and why no why no why
no why and they won't be able to get
that back mm-hmm so it's me it was just
common sense I'm like thinking how can I
get an advantage oh start earlier yeah
let's do that how do you how do you
develop that or where do you what do you
learn that from well I I think it's just
no it's just a matter of what's
important to you mm-hmm what's important
to you for whatever reason you know I I
felt like I didn't feel good about
myself if I wasn't doing everything I
could to be the best version of myself
if I felt like I left anything on the
table it would eat away at me I want to
be able to look myself in the mirror
okay so the reason why I can retire it
now and be completely comfortable about
it because
I know that I've done everything I could
to be the best basketball player I could
be and so that's where it comes from for
me you can't leave any stone unturned
rule number 14 don't fear failure when
you think about your risk tolerance for
failure how far are you willing to fail
well I mean unfortunately unfortunately
I felt quite a bit okay you know but I
understand that's actually part of the
process of succeeding I'm not one that
really believe in failure I believe you
have setbacks and you know you have to
learn from those you have to learn what
are those landlines that can be avoided
the next time
what are those pitfalls you have to
learn from that stuff so you know
welcome those things it's a part of life
but are you prepared to like really fail
it's something totally new like what if
you're just a VC do not my VC yeah you
know and then I work at it and then I'm
not as you see the next yeah you know
whenever it happened yeah listen aya my
first year in league on national TV
18 years old I got shot five straight
air balls in the playoffs in front of
millions of people yeah I think my time
is pretty high yeah yeah I think I'm all
right right rule number 15 have patience
when you play a game or you train you
see immediate results right you see that
right there you know I worked on pull up
jump shot going left I could see the
results that night right and the
business world is different you know you
have to have the patience you have to
find beauty in the process of building
something to find beauty in the journey
and understand that the end result it's
not really the most beautiful part of it
so it's having that patience rule number
16 loves the game the passion came from
the love for the game you know I loved
everything about it
like the smell of the ball you love the
smell of the ball yes the ball you know
the smell of like brand-new sneakers and
like the sound the ball mace when it
hits the ground sneakers and the Jinja -
yeah the ball going through the net like
all those things I love and so the
passion comes from that because once you
have that love you
just want to be a part of this thing all
the time is there one moment where you
can say it defined your passion for
basketball is their story or moment when
you said yeah that wasn't it that was it
that was like when I felt really
passionate no it doesn't never leave
never leaves like that you know the game
was just a part of me so it never leaves
even now that I'm retired you know
everything I've learned from the game of
basketball carried it over into life
mm-hmm
you know like basketballs helped me be a
better person a better friend but I'll
say oh well because there's life lessons
that are within the game like
communications like unselfishness my
attention to detail and empathy and
compassion like all those things are in
the game and as an athlete if we are
aware of those things it helps us become
better human human beings and you can
apply that toward your post post
basketball game retirement into your
business world surely true ventures sure
I mean you can play you know I was
applying that even while I was playing
just in life outside of the game and
even more so now you know in building a
business and all these things you kind
of culture you when I have and all those
things are or directly learn from the
game of basketball to me rule number 17
find new challenges and your mind
Killian it became something words okay
this is this is immediate
the end of my career could be now so
since I was 21 years old and thinking
okay I have to figure out what comes
next
you kind of brainstorm your ID aide but
you never really executed and when the
injury happened is I okay no I needed to
start building now right and that's when
the turning point was for me but I'm
sitting there and I have you kilise
injury it's one thing to sit there and
try to black out the frustrations of
being injured because that's you're
constantly tugging but that right as
opposed to simply replacing that with a
new challenge that's something that gets
you excited so now you're not focused on
not being depressed you're focused on
the excitement of building something and
so it's extremely exciting man having to
figure something out and build it rule
number eighteen focus
Kobi Inc in this venture capital from
her a lot to take on are there other
other things it seems like kind of each
of your vehicles maybe has a specific
purpose are there other areas and things
that you're looking at and want to
pursue it spacing right because you know
we have there are certain things that we
want to get to but we have to pace those
out because we have to have absolute
focus on a few of those things right
Brian stipple fun and the stories that
we are creating right those are two
lenses right now there are other things
that are going to come but that's way
down the road you know we have to have a
very very sharp winds because we can't
do so many things May that's the hardest
part when we first started it is you
have so many people coming from
different different angles different
points of view and you can do this you
can do that and you know it's a lot of
them are very lucrative offers but their
small window my opportunities
and the hardest parts been pushing those
to the side and going for things that
have a much much longer tail which is
risky but you know what are you gonna do
nice think that's the best way to go
about it
rule number 19 creates something
timeless you want to be known long-term
as Kobe Bryant the storyteller and
business person who happened to be a
basketball player or the basketball
player who had a successful career
thereafter no it depends who you talk to
talking to you oh I'm saying if you
asked a question to a writer who's never
seen a basketball game before I would
love to be known as the kick-ass
storyteller all right if you talk to an
athlete that doesn't like reading a book
for anything and I'd like to be known as
a phenomenal basketball player right
personally I would love to be both
because I am both alright you can't
shelf one for the other I mean the game
has brought me to where I am today you
know the investment platform the
Bryant's I will platform the
storytelling that we're doing is going
to put me where I will be 20 years from
now we really want to create something
that is epic and the patient's making
sure every detail is cared for making
sure you're hitting the proper beats
from a plot perspective all right you
know the patient's the detail
rule number 20 be a legend I have
decided to skip college and take my
talents to the NBA
oh it means it's a team what about
individually he's got one more check
[Music]
so you could take that to the bank
[Music]
[Music]
no you promise me one thing
so I made 50 that night no what you guys
learned from about your team from this
series and how's it going to help you
improve moving on in this place holder
in a part-time job you guys were awful
you suck whatever you think you think
you guys deserve all the beating that's
took in the media a lot of times writers
when they write stuff like that means
they care they're Laker fans anyway
we have to get better you have to get
better at playing together you have to
get better that's basically our get
better at ball and Jesus Christ can't
believe I'm saying to you at all that
you just being there to deploy the best
player on T table know for Lord another
bunch of idiots
remember when Kobe Bryant used to dunk
and it wasn't a surprise every time he
dunks it's a big deal
season but here's some vintage kober and
even I thought he's gonna pull up here
but he rips through barns and goes to
the
[Applause]
[Music]
thirteen
[Applause]
don't
the Nagas
when the technical [ __ ]
[Applause]
because the technical because the bids
of the Lakers
[Applause]
to the floor you take a look Chris Rock
sitting right next to Kobe Bryant
shooting the breeze funniest man in the
world telling jokes and take a look at
Kobe Bryant
I don't even hear you
[Music]
[Applause]
mom Wow rule number 21 have a champions
mentality I played one of the things
that had to learn is how to get the best
out of my teammates yeah and most people
think it's a simple thing you know
passing the ball yeah but that's not how
you make guys better you have to really
affect their behavior how do you do that
so yeah like I would tell guys we got
two back to backs you know I don't care
for in Miami I don't care if we're in a
great city of Chicago you can't go out
you got your rest right back to my game
sacked back at ya Fri Monday Tuesday
play Monday and play again Tuesday guys
I don't listen right you don't you're
right so few times here all right we'll
all go out we'll go out together really
I'll drink with you
right but the next morning I'm banging
on your door at 5:00 in the morning
let's go they're not going where are we
going
I'll hung out with you now you come hang
out with me this is what we do all right
let's go you're at the gym we're working
out right we hit the bus we go to
practice we play that night and they're
dead and they're dead they're like
lesson learned lesson learned take them
out once listen if you're gonna do that
do that but don't let that compromise
we're here to do right this is why we're
here this is why you're here in the
first place Yeah right and if we're
gonna win a championship we have to have
that championship mentality it's it work
ethic that's it so you got to show them
low Cole can do that and still has the
energy to get up and do this so either I
got to meet that same energy or I got to
keep my but I'm gonna matter early yeah
rule number 22 outwork your potential I
think the best way to prove your value
is to work is to learn is to absorb to
be a sponge you always want to outwork
your potential as hard as you believe
you can work you can work harder than
that and that's what I try to do when I
first came and lead but you know
basketball is such a direct competition
sport that me coming in at 17 I needed
when like my teammates would say you
know I did hit with an elbow right Shaq
with hit me with an elbow in practice
and like
you know it big man actor will come up
and say are you okay
what Mao are you okay hello how would
you know it's so like I always had that
extra chip on my shoulder so like every
day I practice for me it was really
trying to annihilate everybody that was
that I was playing against cuz I wanted
to prove you don't need to babysit me
like I'm fine you know and and so as
always that competitive nature the work
ethic and curiosity because I asked a
lot of questions you know playing with
Barnes god I asked him a lot of
questions Eddie Jones who was great at
chasing cars off the screens and I
didn't understand how to do that I would
sit with him before practice after
practice magic James Worthy her Rambis
Kareem Abdul all the Laker grades I
would always sit down and just asking
questions about certain games that I've
studied growing up what actually
happened there what did you feel there
and why you know bird tough to defend
why cuz you look slow to me I'm up like
I'm missing something so like tell me
what I'm missing you know anything and
so I would always ask questions and try
to learn as much as I could rule number
23 learn from failures we talk about
this often and we always talk about the
fact that you can learn a lot more from
the failures and you can from the
successes and you have to figure out
where those landmines are and then how
to best avoid those or put or help
entrepreneurs and ourselves included
figure out the clues of where those
landlines are not that you're going to
avoid all of them right but it's also
when you do step on one figuring out
okay how do you recuperate how do you
balance back and you know pick yourself
up rule number 24 be a long-term thinker
I had a summer I played basketball I was
like 10 or 11 years old and a very
prominent some really good Philadelphia
called the Sun you'll be my father
played my uncle played they were like
all-time greats yeah some stuff and Wilt
Chamberlain played in league
or other Perlman role-playing lead and
how come playing and I don't score one
point the entire summer
really not one how old were you 11 10 11
you're playing against other 10 11
year-old start and you didn't score once
not one were you in the game I was in a
game how'd you not score because I was
terrible
really yeah that had 11 years old you
were that awful I mean I you know and I
had these big knee pads on because I'm
wrong we fast I have socks all we up
here and I had like the pod top TV like
skinny as hell and I squirt not a
free-throw not a nothing not a lucky
shot not a breakaway layup zero points
is that when you think the mentality of
hard work started to come in for you at
that age when you failed so miserably I
guess that's somewhere I think that's
when the idea of understanding a
long-term view became important because
I wasn't going to catch these kids in a
week I wasn't gonna catch him in a year
right so that's when I sat down and said
okay this is when it takes him father
all right we'd all want to work on first
all right shooting all right let's knock
this out let's focus on this half a year
six months do nothing but shoot right
after that all right creating your own
shot and you focused so you start I
started creating a menu of things when I
came back the next summer I was a little
bit better right men you'd be like I've
got my jump shot from 15 I've got yeah I
got my job in 15 I got my three-point
shot like just open shots not miss open
shots right and be able to shoot it with
speed because those kids are so much
more athletic yeah and then the next
time I came back as a little better the
summer came back was a little bit I
scored yeah it wasn't much but I scored
this all 12 13 12 13 then 14 came around
back half of 13 14 years old and then I
was just killing everyone and it
happened in two years and I wasn't
expecting to happen in two years but it
did because what I had to do was work on
the basics and the fundamentals while
they relied on an athletics ISM and
their natural ability and because I
stick to the fundamentals it just caught
up to him and then my body you know my
knees stopped hurting I grew into my
frame and and then your athleticism once
you have the fundamental exactly the
hard work the mindset and you tack on
the 11
and then it was game Wow so from 13 your
good average still that was good that
was good about about like the end of my
like right when I was turning 14 I
became best clear in the state at 14 or
14 so I'm from 12 to 14 you went from
scoring 0 to being the best in the state
of all ages yep
rule number 25 find your passion I hope
you talk about hard work all the time
this night you know man if you got to
get up every single morning remind
yourself how hard you need to work your
I need to choose a different profession
you know because that shouldn't be there
is that I wake up in the morning excited
to get to it you know if I'm not
training I'm missing it I'm not watching
the game a bass I miss it you know
there's no place I'd rather be
and if you have that feeling then you're
truly doing with God has put you on this
earth to do rule number 26 challenge
yourself to grow you were quoted in on
CNBC as saying that you'd rather be
remembered for your role in
jump-starting tech companies then your
skills on the court can you talk to them
but what's that about it I think you
have to challenge yourself to evolve and
to grow and I think I couldn't think of
a better message for your athletes in
particular because it's it's very easy
for us athletes to kind of lose
ourselves in our identity by connecting
who we are to what we do and I think
that's a very dangerous zone to be in
right so it's it's common sense to me to
be able to say okay the next stage I'm
going after with the same intensity same
attention to detail the same curiosity
so of course I'd want to be better at
that than I was in my previous career
there's a pretty high bar though you
have you have enough energy left for
that orange I guess we're gonna find out
right I mean that that's the thing you
know you go for it and you do all you
can you learn as much as you can't you
continue to try to continue to improve
you continue to evolve the agency where
you are right 20 years from now you can
have to look at the mirror and say I
gave it my best shot and we did the best
we could and see where we end up rule
number 27
keep going there's a quote from
my English teachers at Lower Merion
named mr. Fisk
I had a great quote that said rest at
the end not in the middle and that's
something I always live by you know I'm
not gonna rest I'm gonna keep on pushing
now there are a lot of answers and I
don't have even questions that I don't
have but I'm just going to keep going
it's going to keep going and I'll figure
these things out as you go alright and
you just continue to build that way so I
try to live by that all the time
rest at the end rest at the end rule
number 28 protect your dreams dreams is
a they should be pure I think a lot of
times we're born into this world we
actually wound up going backwards and it
seems like the more we mature the more
responsible our dreams become and the
more governors we put on ourselves and
our ability to dream and to reimagine
and it's always a fight for his parents
and for you guys to make sure that your
dreams always stay pure and so it's not
a matter of pushing beyond the
limitations of expectations it's really
a matter of protecting your dreams
protecting your imagination that's
really the key and when you do that then
the world just seems limitless
rule number 29 be driven on journey
began in Philadelphia Pennsylvania the
age of three years old my father putting
a basketball my hands and me taking it
from there
basketball was in Kobe's blood his dad
is Joe jellybean Brian he played eight
years in the NBA before uprooting his
family to take his career overseas as a
grow older we moved to Italy while Joe
was getting used to playing in Europe
his son was also making an adjustment in
Italy not many kids were perfecting a
jump shot but Kobe Bryant was soccer was
a big sport so he had goalposts
underneath the baskets on concrete
courts were kids used to play soccer all
day and I would be one of them and then
after soccer I'd stay there for another
three four or five hours is playing
basketball it was a different country
with a different language even though he
had his family he was essentially alone
so Kobe looked inland and developed the
relentless drive to work on his game
[Applause]
when his family moved back to
Philadelphia that time spent alone on
the court paid off as Kobe announced his
arrival to the basketball world he was
the top high school player in the
country
breaking Wilt Chamberlain scoring
records becoming a celebrity at 16
Kobe's next step may have seen Dan
Vicious but with his basketball pedigree
and work ethic it was an easy decision
[Music]
yeah rule number 30 achieve greatness
[Music]
right now right yeah I remember season 1
do you say who is this kid
it's 20th season all have no make
various careers in basketball I will not
allow them to be what do you want water
any longer no one understand what it
takes to be great the force that drives
you to do what others don't
the sacrifice is made all with one
purpose in mind
push yourself and become better the
extra seconds minutes hours of work put
into perfecting one's game lifting
yourself above the rest to make sure
your name will forever be synonymous
with one word greatness what does it
take to be great work at the combination
drive takes ability it takes it desire
moves on muscle again turns it I think
it takes years of players relying on you
to take the big shot make the great play
you know do the things that bring
success to the team that's that's what
it's all about is getting out and
measure yourself against others and I
think that when you have an attitude
like that that's what I think that's
part of greatness the first time met
Kobe Kobe was just out of high school
he's out here poor work up and I've
never seen anyone work out this hard
this is Kovac I've never seen anybody
that prepared he was 17 years old and
was ready to play and be a basketball
that's pretty amazing and I think Jerry
West was the one who said this he said I
want this kid because this kid had more
talent than anybody I have plan for me
right now and he had a great team just
kidding would never take a night off
even if it wasn't going well it was
always going to be trying to slay the
dragon if you don't have that type of
work ethic you don't get to enjoy the
benefits
[Applause]
rule number 31 get better every single
day my philosophy was a very simple one
I am and this is where I think film
plays a big part of my life I Rudy was
one of my favorite films growing up
after watching that film I come to
understand if I could work that hard
every day with being blessed with the
physical tools that I have with my
career being and I made a promise to
myself from that day that I was going to
work that hard every single day so that
when I do retire I have no regrets and
that was the most important thing for me
is to leave no stone unturned get better
every single day
and if I live that way then over time
you know I'd have something that was
beautiful but that was my philosophy it
seems like a pretty simple one but you
know if you live your life to just get
better every single day and do that for
20 years I mean what do you have
rule number 32 prove them wrong where'd
you get your killer interesting from
well yeah I think a lot of it had to do
with isolation growing up over there and
being the only african-american kid not
being able to speak the language I
gravitated towards the game and in that
game you find a lot of you find solace
every day and then when you play with
kids that it might not accept you
because you're an outsider but you know
when we come to play the game that's my
chance to forgive vengeance on the for
not accept Amanda and that's where it
kind of started developing and then
throughout the course of my life it's
always been that it's always been the
outsider and I'm gonna come in and prove
you know
or to seek some sort of vengeance when
apart
rule number 33 work on your weaknesses
you were so dominant your whole career
one of the greatest of all time was
there a weakness that you had the
challenge for me was always compassion
and empathy because you're like guys
let's go
get results shut up don't complain right
I want to hear your whining
I don't know excuses don't tell me how
rough the water is just bring the boat
in you know I don't I don't want here
you know and it's funny it's
understanding like okay these guys have
lives rights out of here
they have other things have other things
happening to them that may be affecting
the way that they're practicing or the
way that they're performing and it was
hard for me to understand that because
nothing nothing bothered me you know
anything personally you know never fazed
me when I'm compartmentalised it very
well but so I couldn't understand how my
teammates couldn't do that either until
I you know I had to really work on that
aspect of it that's hard
rule number 34 execute what you
practiced in 2006 against the Toronto
Raptors you scored 81 points which is
second only to Wilt Chamberlain's
hundred points you know I always dreamed
as a kid that you know it was possible
to score at 80 or 90 100 oh it's just
like you know had a dream you know like
sometimes we lay down in bed and you
visualize things you just kind of you
know just that's how that's at least how
I would go to sleep I lay down and I'd
imagine playing for the Lakers and I'll
imagine with the uniforms look like I'd
imagine we would be playing and you know
the smell of the arena and all sort of
stuff and I would see myself you know
getting hot you know score ten straight
points and then but in the dream like
why would you ever interrupt that like
you're not going to have a dream and be
like okay Nene misses his next six but
it's not going to happen so you just
keep dreaming a dream in a dream and
then before I go to sleep I'm like at a
hundred and twenty points No so who's
out when you grow up
loading that into your brain over and
over and over and then you know that
summer I made a thousand shot today
a thousand right that's on top of weight
training and my conditioning I made a
thousand shots and it weren't just shots
it was shots that you saw in that game
there were specific shots I mean it's
coming out of the corner going to the
pinch post footwork in the post coming
off the screen it was very specific so
when you download that into your system
and you go out in the court and you're
just executing things that you've done
thousands of times before and you have
that dream then that becomes possible
yeah everything's been not choreographed
but it's been practiced so many times
that is second nature
there's why we invented like I don't
understand that you go out and play the
game and you're just trying to create
something news no no this is what I do
this is what I do extremely well you
don't have to stop me from doing that
and if you do stop me from doing that I
have a counter to that done rule number
35 learn from greatness
another thing you told me as a 18 year
old I'm gonna be better than Mike so I
knew it definitely drove you and you
know it's always gonna be there those
comparisons when somebody's come before
you and you do it so I'm Alan love you
pattern began about him and I don't know
if you watched in high school but it was
a lot of similarity but I know I know
that day you passed up Michael Jordan I
know you probably ride in your car like
you know what man I thought I would be
just like what happened is when I came
in the league and I wanted to take more
right ready now all I heard was nobody
called the Black Panther to call black
Jesus awesome stuff I said I want to see
this is about and but what happened does
everyone know he wanted to becoming a
big brother too
gah get up quick if you knew why'd you
go over to faith Mike after you faithful
ball we all salute off your feet
everywhere else you go homie game I go
for you explore these real great he saw
something me that reminded him a lot of
himself and he was coming up and took me
under his wing a lot they showed me a
lot of things taught me a lot of things
I leadership things
[Music]
[Applause]
so when I pass him up member talking to
Matthew with him saying you know this is
kind of good since he's still here
information and the stuff that he's
passed on to me I'm breathing that
spirit back into the game all over yet
which is a lot of reason why I try to be
bad out the next generation because you
did that for me
Bill Russell two different jerry west
you guys but michael in particular rule
number 36 learned from wins and losses
what is losing feel like to you it's
exciting why is it exciting because it
means you have different ways to get
better there are certain things that you
can figure out that you can take
advantage of right certain weaknesses
that were exposed that you need to shore
up right so it was exciting I mean it's
sucks to lose and ran but at the same
time
their answers there if you just look at
them because you get the information
from losing more than from winning
probably yeah yeah I mean the answers
are there when you win to you you just
have to look at them yeah right so it's
a constant process it's exciting when
you wait it's exciting when you lose
because the process should be exactly
the same whether you win or you lose is
you go back and you look and you find
things that you could have done better
you find things that you've done well
that worked
figure out how did they work why did
they work how can you make them work
again yeah and but the hardest thing is
to face that stuff that's a really tough
challenge you may face a mean look
yourself in the mirror and say okay this
is how I showed up or this is what
happened and I give an example so katie
lou sanderson is one of the best college
basketball players in the country she
plays at uconn she's gonna be a senior
right now right now yeah and she's from
Huntington Beach out here by us and so
she comes down and she works with some
my girls on the team and she helps coach
and yeah and they just had a really
tough season last year but he lost a
Notre Dame in a final that's right
really to first loss on her slopes years
right and so I asked I say have you
watched a Notre Dame game it's just a
hole so well why not I know you don't
but you're gonna play Notre Dame this
year yeah yeah it was the chances you
see him again
and
probably Mia said well you can't show up
and play them without knowing why you
lost that one right so you know the
mistakes that you've made in that game
you have to do the hard stuff and watch
that game and study that game to not
make those mistakes over and over again
just because you weren't brave enough to
face it so she came down to the office I
brought down the officer we sat down we
watched that game together all right did
you got a got a deal with it got a deal
with it face it learn from it
Wow there must have been cringing for
her and she's like oh you playing like
we could have won all the things that's
exactly it is I just did that one thing
is that if I didn't get that foul for a
squad a layup it's exactly right you're
looking I said oh there's the mismatch
oh there's the gap uh you know and all
those little things and it sucks but but
you don't want to have that feeling
again do you right so you got to really
study it face it and not to say you'll
win the next time you fade but your
least you give yourself a better better
chance yeah rule number 37 practice
mindfulness you have a mindfulness or
meditative practice that you use while
you play yeah well Phil introduced
meditation to us when he came to our
team in 99 mm and it was something that
I instantly gravitated to because I
could see the effects and you I used to
watch you know studying the games the
Bulls teams and you know watching their
demeanor watching their composure and
playing in a tough place like Utah doing
the finals and being down 17 but
everybody was like this you couldn't
tell if they were down 17 or up 20 or
tie game and never changed and I was
wondering why the hell that is
and that's why I started doing more
research and when till came I
immediately gravitated to it then found
myself accepted the challenge of finding
what that space is and for the 81 point
game and to be honest I was wasn't even
thinking about the game my knee was
hurting so much
I didn't know then but you know how to
flap a joint cartilage stuck in my joint
mine and so my mom was really trying to
go to a place where I don't feel that
pain and game started and because of
that I was just in a different space I
wasn't worried about what was the calm I
was worried about which is happening I
was just here and when you're just there
in the moment playing plays right in
front of you your focus is heightened
because nothing else matters and that's
the space I've tried to get to rule
number 38 be ambitious you remember what
you told me one day before when I first
met you you said you were going to be
the finish it for me like the greatest
player of all time yes you can be torn
up now that sounds that sounds something
no it sounds like something I would say
no she said that and then you actually
said it will be the will sniff of the in
beer
yeah now you know I've always had
ambition rule number 39 believe in your
team what are you most proud of from
your 20 seasons honestly whose sounds
may sound a little shallow but I got to
say beating the Celtics in Game seven
that's what I'm most proud of because we
want it was the hardest you know you're
playing with rajon rondo Paul Pierce
mm-hmm Kevin Garnett hmm I'll stop Ray
Allen and you know there's myself pow
and players that other teams didn't won
and you know how do we figure out as a
group what to do and the reason why I
loved that series so much is that we
went down three games to two against
Boston and now you got two games coming
home I remember sitting in the locker
room and they beat the crap out it was
to that game so we're sitting in a
locker room and it's really really quiet
I'm sitting there looking around and we
just lost the Celtics in know eight so
this is like revenge right now kicking
our butt again right so I sit around I
just started laughing I started laughing
and
I remember Derek Fisher looked at me
like and Lamar I looked at me goes but
what is funny said do they beat the crap
just beat the crap up and say I'm
missing the part where that's funny I
said man listen if we start this season
and they say you know all you have to do
is win two games at home and your NBA
champ would you take that yeah right
that's all we got to do yeah go home b2
into four NBA champions oh yeah Jews
would to get two games a row that's it
we'll take care of the first game and I
promise you they're not winning Game
seven on our home floor it's not
happening so we all just laughed about
it and then we went out and we figured
it out but that Game seven was we're
down 15 points in the fourth quarter
right and that's when you have to
collectively look at each other and say
you know the spirit of your team must be
good because at that moment is when
teams fracture if the energy amongst
each other isn't there that trust isn't
there you're done mmm
and we were able to collectively dig
deep together and say all right we're
gonna figure this thing out Wow and I
wasn't playing well I always shooting
the ball well at all and so my teammates
picked you up and they delivered yes
yeah rule number 40 learned storytelling
storytelling for me is the number one
thing it's write its outline is creating
narratives that inspire the next
generation of athletes what are those
things and you know not from merely a
documentary perspective but from a
fantasy perspective from the mythology
perspective right what are those stories
that we can use to teach the next
generation of athletes not just about
the sport but teach them about life
through sport how do we make those
connections
and so that's why I obsess over every
single day
rule number 41 elevate others here's
where practice was important to me not
only just the standpoint that I enjoy
playing like I enjoyed being there I
enjoy getting better but as a leader of
a team it's also your responsibility to
elevate the rest of the guys and what
people will tend to get stuck on a lot
as saying okay the way to make players
better it's the past of the ball when
they're open that's a very trivial way
to look at things but you have to do is
you have to get them emotionally to want
to be better you want you have to get
them to an emotional space where they
wake up every morning driven to be the
best version of themselves right how do
you do that and in practice for me it
was a chance to drive them to challenge
them right if they're and this is where
you have to know your teammates because
if it's late just had two back-to-back
and we had practice the next day you
show up guys don't feel like going
through the motions don't feel like
practicing it's important to know each
and every one of them individually
personally because then you know what
nerve to touch some guys it's like okay
come on let's know we can do this
that'll get them going are the guys you
know you got to figure out what button
to push you know Powell was always Spain
if I tell them how they lost in a gold
medal to us and how they're gonna lose
again I'm gonna beat your ass in
practice just like I beat you in a gold
medal game all that all you Tate that
you hate that but that's what practice
what you have to drive them you
absolutely have to and if practice is
more intense and harder than a game
seven will be in a game seven will be
easy but if it's not then that's when
teams start folding and capitulating
rule number 42 wanted the most one thing
what I love the budget eighty notice as
he wanted it
a lot of guys on our team didn't want it
but you wanted it had a 18 on it and
that's why the Utah game everybody talks
about this airballs I wasn't mad at you
that's why I was the first one to come
grab me and say hey I know everybody's
laughing and giggling that but one day
people will fear you at the end of the
game so I knew that about just 1830
older you know was it was fun
rule number 43 expect excellence have
you noticed a moment where you're like I
can't maybe I can't be as intense as I
was during sports I can't demand people
to be here till midnight or practice
without a ball for three hours or no
listen my thing is really simple here is
that you know I expect excellent work we
all do so I don't care if you're here in
the office at 6 a.m. and you leave at
midnight if the work that you do is
average this is not the home for you
conversely you cannot be in office at
all and have excellent work this is the
place for you so I don't really care if
you're here there's a lot of guys that
get in the gym and work hard work hard
work hard work hard but then they can't
transition that to 7:30 Yeah right
rule number 44 be a champion what it was
like for you with all of the grit and
all of the makeup that you had to be
such a great competitor what was it like
for you to play with people that that
weren't as gritty as you were how did
you deal with that how did you set your
expectations knowing that that you were
so far out there and and how did you
deal with the players that you played
with you know when knowing that they
they were still kind of somewhere on the
spectrum but but you're on the top of it
good question it's a great question um
my response might sound a little tough
but I just I kill him I bury him
you know this is you know tolerance for
that and the kind of culture that the
Laker organization stood for when in
Championships is not tolerated you're
gonna show up to play and you're gonna
allow the gags through the scrimmage
through this drill I'm going to beat you
I'm going to let you know I beat you I'm
gonna want you to reconsider your
professional life choice for the most
part people will say okay that doesn't
make a great teammate well I'm not gonna
be a great teammate I'm here to help you
win championships so here's a difference
and you know fortunately for us for me
you know we had an organization that it
was Championships or nothing and they
were really good about identifying that
and bringing players in here that had
that competitive streak and getting rid
of the ones that denied if I got a fight
to get you in the gym that's a problem
that's a problem you want players that
are gym rats players at wannabe in the
gym that want to work and then from
there you build on top of that but if
you're lazy man I don't want to talk to
you I want to deal with you you don't
make me feel Dumber you know you know
you're gonna lower my level I don't
think so you can go over there there's
plenty of teams in here where you'll fit
right in
that's not ha ha you mentioned at the
time they were right down the hall from
us that's no easy hunt
they were rule number 45 focus on
winning 96 through 99 was a frustrating
point I don't know about well maybe a
little bit for you but for me being one
of the best babes in the league and
having that title of not winning one I
remember one day reading it reading and
the paper Oh Shaq so average in 20 or 30
of doing this and the great Kareem
abdul-jabbar said well he didn't win
then yet parent so is he great and I
just kind of I just kind of yeah no I I
want to know I understood where's your
necessity to have to win one there was a
lot of pressure and I think there's a
lot of frustration because you kept
seeing this kid and everybody kept
saying could be patient with this kid be
patient with this kid and you're saying
listen I don't have patience I have to
win now and this kid needs a develop now
I think I could remember the first time
we had our first fight and you look this
el kid is crazy at this yeah it was
we're playing a pickup games or a
lockout season Southwest college playing
a pickup game we're on opposite teams
run and trash talking yes and you kept
saying yeah it take to hello
take that oh I'm looking around oh yes
right and I say Oh hold on I ain't gonna
be too many more than would you say what
what you gonna do about it what you
gonna do about it and then that's the
next thing I knew I saw a big hand
coming this way and I remember going
this way I remember throwing some
lollipop olden Polynice came and then
they all just kind of broke his part
broke this up I'm looking at this and
I'm saying but he wants this thing is
it's it affects him I mean he's it
consumes him and then from that moment
on I knew we spoke the same language
don't matter if we had disagreements and
saying the other our drive to win like
we have to win there's there's no other
option we're gonna figure this out we
won't get this done and
you did it Electro's have to Brian
rule number 46 love what you do don't
you explain that mindset of just trying
to continuously improve I enjoy what I
do you know this is fun for me
you know III truly love what I do and
that's where the passion comes from
that's where the will to get better
comes from it's just because I truly
enjoy I enjoy the preparation the high
school coach Greg Donner it says that
you might actually be a little
embarrassed by how much you love
basketball yeah is that true probably
yeah I mean well it's like well I mean
it's like anything you know I I just so
happened to be playing basketball like
if I was a computer kid you know in high
school people would have probably been
in front of me you know what I mean it
just so happened to be basketball what
I'm passionate about my passion knows no
bounds but it embarrasses you well I
mean just a little little weird a little
strange I mean when you're around like
in the Olympics I'm around all the
athletes who kind of share that same
shame my same mindset it's it's fun to
be around though because you can have
conversations about those things
three-member 47 don't jump the ship I
know it's good to say to you want to win
the championship everywhere but it
probably wasn't really a realistic one
so how do you would adjust or how do you
adjust as a team leader and then how
what conversations does ownership have
with the coaches well rebuild the teenie
geenie so sweet she saw me worked so
hard for so many years and the last few
years her and Rob who was at the time my
agent called me and said listen we are
so sorry for what happened to this team
we're sorry that we don't have seriously
it's like we don't we're sorry we don't
have a team around you that can contend
for a championship I mean it village
it's so we could make a few calls and
get you on a contending team that's all
because we just feel horrible about
seeing you going out there in Chicago
remember this
and I said they're not listed I said you
know we don't each other for a very long
time up now I'm questioning myself
because I'm wondering what about me
unless you think I would jump ship we
don't do that like the Lakers I've been
a Laker fan since five years old man I
know the Laker history all way from
Minneapolis always worthless today
and so it's in my blood and this family
her father believing in me and standing
by me and also stuff like I'm number I
don't go anywhere like this is home to
me you know we work through this stuff
together and like as a leader I'll be
able to take the good with the bad man
you can't just because of ship sinking
all of a sudden I might jump off a swim
to another [ __ ] like that you don't do
that right you can win championships in
front of everybody then you could miss
the playoffs in front of everybody you
gotta be able to take both sides
rule number 48 learn from the best
remember the first practice we had
Travis Knight on the team and I mean you
proceeded to just annihilate this kid
and you know just from everything from
talking trash to him to you know he was
afraid to get on the bus and one thing
that I noticed about you from the jump
was that you didn't respect people that
you could bully and respect them and you
test them and you'd see would they let
you get away with and you'd see if they
would fold to that and that was the
first thing I observed about you and
that competitive fire that you had and
then it all started making sense
that's how I see him play with that rage
when it comes out that's how I see guys
when he played they back away from it
afraid afraid of that a confrontation
that's physicality and and then I
remember you taking me down to Jerry's
deli back in the day we had the big big
flip phones you know I mean
I don't know you have one point I said
man get one of those man pretty damn
cool yeah you know the big joint and
just hanging out with you men and uh you
show me the ropes from day one
number 49 pork yosity first what are the
characteristics that you're looking
forward to bring in to your team is it
much like you want a teammate for the
Lakers those type of cores or what are
you what are you looking for supportin
thing is curiosity first I want curious
people people that ask questions that
want to figure things out figure out new
ways to do things you know that's the
most important thing and then from that
curiosity having a determination to see
that curiosity through all right to
figure out those steps and if you figure
out okay this is a particular course of
action that we feel like we should be
taking has it been done before no but
that's exciting to me let's figure it
out those are the characteristics that I
look for first and foremost and rule
number 50 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is inspire people
next to you the final question is what's
your definition of greatness I think the
definition of greatness is to inspire
the people next to you yeah I think
that's what greatness is or should be
it's not something that's that that
lives and dies with one person it's how
can you inspire a person to then in turn
inspire another person that then
inspires another person and that's how
you create something that I think lasts
forever and I think that's our challenge
as people is to is to figure out how our
story can impact others and motivate
them in a way to create their own
greatness now I've got a special bonus
tip on how to have the Mamba mentality
with Kobe Bryant that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching a video to taking action in
your life for business here we go
question number one who are three people
who are the best at what they do that
you need to learn from number two who
can you elevate in your life today and
number three where do you need to
challenge yourself to grow I've broken a
book up into two sections and process is
really about the process of preparing
you know through injury recovery
studying of the game
and then the craft is the actual
performance and the tactics and so a lot
of things that I learned through the
game were through photos you can look at
a photo and see like a player making a
movie look at the angle of his feet look
how I was using his hands on defense and
I can really break down things to the
smallest detail through that and that's
what you'll see in this book I mean it's
really a basketball Bible
yeah mama meant it but it's also your
mindset Bible right yeah yeah I might
would you see how I break things down
like how I'm looking at things to the
smallest of detail yeah and that's the
best way to understand how to have that
kind of mentality is to ask questions
then find answers and then lead to more
questions and you find more answers and
that's what a book is if you want to
have an incredible work ethic like Kobe
Bryant check the video right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it and you
need to believe and I'll see you there
just kidding you'll never take a night
off even if it wasn't calling well it
was always going to be trying to slay
the dragon